تتواصل التساؤلات بشان موقف اسرائيل من
حكم محكمه العدل الدوليه الذي اتخذته في
قضيه اتهام جنوب افريقيا لها بارتكاب
جرائم ترقع الى مستوى الاباده الجماعيه
حول هذا الموضوع انضم الينا الان من
جوهانسبورغ وزير العدل في جنوب افريقيا
السيد رونالد لامولا سيد لامولا ارحب بك
وابدا معك اذا بشان هذا القرار لمحكمه
العدل الدوليه يوم الجمعه الماضي الذي لم
ينطق في الواقع بوقف لاطلاق النار هل
تفهمون
ذلك قد تكون المحكمه لم تذكر وقف اطلاق
النار في قرارها لكن عندما تقرا الاوامر
التدابير الاحترازيه
المؤقته فعند تطبيقها هي ترقى الى مساله
وقف اطلاق النار
حقيقه الامتناع عن قتل الناس
ومسائله المسؤولين الاسرائيلين الذين
يحرضون على العنف ويسمحون وايضا السماح
بال الاغاثات الانسانيه بالدخول وغيرها
بالتالي عندما نقرا كل ما امرت به المحكمه
فهو يرقى الى وقف لاطلاق النار وهذا ما
نفهمه نحن اذا بتقييمكم اليوم اسرائيل
فعلا باتت تحت الرصد و الرقابه كما يجب هل
الدعوه التي رفعتموه وصلت الى
مبتغاها نعم نعم القضيه قد حققت غرضها حقا
وخلال شهر وكما جاء في امر المحكمه ستتلقى
تقريرا من اسرائيل من اجل ان تراقب اذا ما
تم الاتباع والامتثال لتدابير احترازيه
التي اتت بها المحكمه وامتثلت اسرائيل لها
وحقيقه ان
هذه يجب ان يكون
هنالك تغيير فعلي في حياه الفلسطينين في
غزه وايضا الامين العام للامم المتحده قال
دائما انه لا يمكن ان يكون هنالك تدخل او
مساعدات انسانيه تدخل غزه بدون وقف لاطلاق
النار بالتالي نحن نتوقع ان يتم تمكين
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه في غزه ويتم
تمكين هذا الدخول عن طريق دوله
اسرائيل وان يتمون هنالك وقف فوري للقصف
واستهداف البنى والمنشات التحتيه المدنيه
لكن سيد لامولا كما تعلم تل ابيب يعني نفت
نيه الاباده هذه وترفض اتهامات جنوب
افريقيا وتقول بان سقوط مدنيين في كل
الاحوال وفي كل حرب هذا شيء متوقع وطبيعي
وتضيف يعني يعني تقول لجنوب افريقيا لقد
قدمتم حقائق وصور سرديه وقانونيه مشوهه
بشكل عميق هل لديكم اي رد على هذا
الكلام ما نعمل به الان هو ونعتمد عليه
توصلت اليه المحكمه وهي التدابير
الاحترازيه المؤقته
و وقدمتها و
بها دوله اسرائيل بالتالي المحكمه وج حججا
كافيه ودلائل واضحه على خطر حصول الاباده
الجماعيه الحكومه عفوا المحكمه لم تقبل
الحجج والدفوع التي ت اتت بها اسرائيل
وطلبت انه يجب ان يتم السماح بالدخول
المساعدات الانسانيه وايقاف تدمير البنى
التحتيه المدنيه اذ ان كل هذا الامر يمثل
امتثالا لاوامر
يرهب على نح مختلف من قبل دوله اسرائيل
علينا ان نلتزم بتدابير المحكمه ونضمن
تطبيقها طيب دعنا نعود قليلا الى الوراء
يعني في اي لحظه
بالتحديد تبلورت هذه الخطوه بانكم لابد
ومن الضروري ان تتقدم بهذه الدعوه وتتحرك
قضائيا ضد
اسرائيل
كما قد تكون على علم فان اسرائيل هي موقعه
على دوله موقعه على اتفاقيه منع جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه في ونحن ايضا دوله موقعه
وايضا وايضا تم تاكيد توقيع عليها من قبل
وزير العدل في جنوب افريقيا من اجل ان
نضمن عدم حدوث هذه الجريمه وكنا ندفع
بحل الدولتين منذ الوقت طويل لكن عندما
تصاعد العنف وازداد القصف فان بدات النيه
الواضحه
لارتكاب جريمه الاباده الجماعيه وبسبب
الدمار الكبير شعرنا ان هنالك التزاما
اخلاقيا وتاريخيا علينا ان نقدم ندفع بهذه
القضيه للدفاع عن المستضعفين من النساء
والاطفال
خصوصا وقد وظف شرح كما شرحه الامين العام
الوضع في غزه بانه غير مسبوق
لان وبالتالي قمنا بتقديم هذه القضيه
للمحكمه بشكل سريع طيب يعني ما تم في هاي
مؤخرا وهذا القرار لمحكمه العدل الدوليه
وصف من قبل الكثيرين وحتى من قبل
اسرائيليين بانه انتصار يحسب لجنوب
افريقيا كيف تفسر هذا الانتصار هل هي
استراتيجيه تم اتباعها من قبل فريقكم ام
ان هناك عوامل اخرى لعبت
ايضا هو انتصار لحكم القانون الدولي
وبالنسبه لنا لكي نبنى نبني نظاما قانونيا
ودوليا صحيحا
وايضا بامكان الدول المختلفه في المجتمع
الدولي ان تعيش مع بعضها البعض كان قرارا
من الحكومه الذي قاده الرئيس ام بوسا وانا
اعتقد انه سمح لنا
بالتقدم في هذه القضيه كان قراره قرارا
شجاعا وايضا شكل فريق قانوني من اجل ضمان
ان يتم تنفيذ هذا القرار من اجل لاخذ
الامر الى المحكمه فيما يتعلق
بالتزام باتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه
وايضا جمع المعلومات واخذ الموضوع الى
المحكمه بالتالي نعتقد ان هذا فعلا
اكد على القانون والمجتمع الدولي الذي يجب
ان يحترم دور القانون وايضا يجب ان تتبعه
دوله اسرائيل ونعتقد ان هذا ستكون نهايه
فلات من العقاب الذي تمتعت به اسرائيل
ويجب ان يكون هنالك دعم لحقوق الانسان
ودفاع عن حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني بتقديرك
هذا القرار لمحكمه هل يفتح الطريق امام
اشياء اخرى اهم سواء على صعيد الحرب او
على صعيد الراي العام العالمي ايضا وربما
يؤثر حتى في اراء بعض الداعمين ربما
لاسرائيل بالسلاح
وغيره
نعم نعم نعتقد انه س يناشد الضمير الجمعي
للمجتمع
الدولي
وايضا يدعو دوله اسرائيل للاستماع الى
ضميرها لا يمكنهم ان يستمروا
بدعم دوله وجدتها الحكومه عفوا المحكمه
تقوم ب لديها دلائل واضحه على الخراط في
عمليه الاباده الجماعيه
وايضا نحاول ان
ننهي القصف المستمر ونمكن ايضا المجتمع
الدولي من ان يضغط بشكل مباشر ومناسب على
اسرائيل لاننا في الوقت الذي نعتمد فيه
على الوكالات المختلفه من الامم المتحده
لكن يجب ان يكون هنالك لدى المجتمع الدولي
والدول المجتمع الدولي يجب ان تلعب دورا
فعالا من اجل ان نضمن وقف قتل المدنيين
الابرياء في غزه
ونحن سعدنا لرؤيه الكثير من الدول منها
البرازيل مثلا وتركيا ودول الجامعه
العربيه ودول اخرى تدعو لتطبيق امر
المحكمه وكما تعرفون كنا واضحين جدا ان
الامر يتعلق بحقوق الانسان لشعبي في
فلسطين وقمنا بادانه افعال لحماس في
السابع من اكتوبر وقد اشرنا بذلك حتى في
مرافعتها في القضيه اسئله كثيره طبعا كنت
اود ان اسالها لكن الوقت انتهى شكرا جزيلا
لك اذا وزير العدل في جنوب افريقيا رونالد
لامولا شكرا لك